so it's not just that you've got some
foot soldiers out there and again you
are allowed to protest you can't protest
in the middle of the street okay you
shouldn't be going to people's homes i
have never liked that and and
there may be some gray area this is what
i've heard a few people say there's a
little bit of a gray area whether you
can protest outside peaceful people's
homes now if you do it peacefully
outside people's homes
i think some of this is left up to the
local laws but we just have to realize
what are we unearthing what are we
unearthing and let's let's do a reverse
version of the video that i just showed
you let's say that was a bunch of
right-wingers
right-wing people protesting outside the
house of a lefty justice say sotomayor
let's say there was a bunch of them that
weren't happy with her decision and they
were outside we'd be being told that
they were terrorists that they were all
right they were being instigated by
scary people like tucker carlson or dave
rubin et cetera et cetera but now it's
going to basically be excused and if you
don't believe me well here's that
gensake woman and this is jen saki on
friday
basically saying yeah you guys can do
whatever you want outside of his house
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point look i think the president's
view is that there's a lot of passion a
lot of fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected we want
people to protest peacefully if they
want to to protest that is certainly
what the president's view would be so he
doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence i don't have
an official us government position on
where people protest i want it we want
it of course to be peaceful and
certainly the president would want
people's uh privacy to be respected but
i think we shouldn't lose the point here
the reason people are protesting is
because women across the country are
worried about their fundamental rights
that have been law for 50 years their
rights to make choices about their own
bodies and their own health care are at
risk that's why people are protesting
they're unhappy they're scared
all right so you guys get it she's
excusing it but she had the word butt in
there right so she is absolutely
excusing and she's saying they have to
be peaceful and that's good so she's not
like outright calling for people to be
assassinated or decapitated and she's
claiming she's for privacy but she is
for it now remember
it's just so obvious like imagine if
this was ruth bader ginsburg's house if
she was still alive and there were
right-wing protesters do you think jen
saki would be up there saying oh well we
just want them to be peaceful and people
are upset and they you know they have a
right to do it like it's just
pure it's pure pure pure pure pure
unadulterated bs that's what it is and
you can see this so what happens is the
lies and the obfuscation of the truth
they get laundered through the
administration and then they get out
through the washington post and the new
york times and cnn and msnbc and
everywhere else here's a opinion piece
in the washington post this is what they
had to say about
protesting outside people's houses the
decisions by supreme court justices have
a direct impact on people's lives such
as the case of texas senate bill 8
denying health care to millions of
pregnant people pregnant people in texas
we used to call them women women back in
my day old school the consequences of
supreme court justice brett m
kavanaugh's actions will be dire and
having protesters outside his home for
one night pales in comparison with what
he and his fellow conservative justices
have inflicted on pregnant people in
this country i mean this person who
wrote this piece is a complete clown
she can't say women she can't say women
and also one night of protests well we
know these protests are going to
continue but the fact that they can't
say women and we just brought in a new
supreme court justice who also can't
decide what a woman is right she's not a
biologist we are they're just dragging
us to the endless descent to hell but
don't worry guys you know me we're going
to have solutions here uh but
you can't do this it doesn't matter if
it's one night or two nights also
they're not attacking women's rights
they are just kicking it back to the
states that's all that they're doing